desperate times for jayaratna and
hundreds of thousands of sri lankans
with prices of feed and fuel increasing
and severe shortages the dairy farmer is
wondering how to continue
i don't think it's possible to go on
because when you look at the cost of
animal feed and the price of a bottle of
milk it's not doable
ultimately the person who makes a profit
is the butcher because the animals end
up there
the government says sri lanka is
bankrupt
this means there's no money for food
medicine fuel and cooking gas
this food delivery rider has told us he
spends more time in cues than he does
working yesterday i was waiting in the
queue for 14 hours to get three liters
petrol so i for three liter spectral i
can work for just six or eight hours
only
which means
it is very difficult to
survive
and al jazeera's team in colombo waited
four days to get enough fuel to shoot
this story
now the fuel has arrived but it will
take another hour or two to get it
because there's a power cut and the shed
has stopped pumping there are
restrictions on how much we get
people are angry and frustrated and
confrontations often turn violent
police and military have been deployed
to keep the peace but there are
accusations of brutality
this footage of an officer assaulting a
motorist has gone viral
on tuesday prime minister ranil
vikramasingha announced his roadmap to
recovery
we're taking part in discussions as a
bankrupt country so it's more difficult
and complicated than before because of
this we have to give the imf a plan on
how we intend to restructure our debt we
can only reach a staff level agreement
if the imf is satisfied with the plan
the plan will be handed to the imf in
august
but patients may run out long before
then everybody after work in a queue
till about 12 o'clock in the night
and next day back to work again
it's very hard the government says the
next petrol shipment is due to arrive on
the 22nd of july but given its inability
to secure supplies in recent weeks plus
dues of more than 735 million dollars
and no foreign reserves people around
here are skeptical
fernandez al jazeera colombo